If the movie you're watching was made recently
portion of what you're seeing is probably computer generated
While some people argue that CGI is cheapening the medium
the market is still booming
and sadly for any science-fiction hipsters out there
it's no longer genre specific either
but despite all the criticism so many amazing things have been brought to life by CGI
that we can't help but stand in awe at the artists and engineers behind the scenes who make the vision come to life
Using a process called chroma keying
they are able to insert a person into an inviroment
but to do so some pretty hilarious things have to happen first
Before we jump into our list can you guess the movie from these emojis
stay tuned for the answer
and if you like what you see feast your eyes on our catalogue of videos by subscribing to our channel
In the meantime though here are Screen Rant's ten funniest moments where actors were replaced by CGI
That things part raptor
(dinosaur groans)
Jurassic World
If we learned anything from the first three Jurassic Park movies
it's that dinosaurs are scary
we've spent decades living in fear as a result
but then jurassic world came along and shattered the meticulously crafted facade
as they're know to do some set photos leaked onto the internet and gave us a humorous glimpse into what life is really like for a velociraptor
and it's far less gnarly than you think
it turns out they're just a bunch of dudes in grey onesies dancing around with silly dino shaped hats atop their noggins
and while that information gives us a good giggle we're also a little jealous
Allowed you
How do you know what that is
Mozzarella of course
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
The inflatable costume has revolutionised the wardrobe industry
and turns any regular Halloween party into a classy Halloween party
after all nothing screams posh more than having to yell all your conversations over the buzzing of a small fan near your crotch
The motion capture actors behind the new teenage mutant ninja turtles know what we're talking about
or at least their onset costumes make it look like they might
People who were familiar with the franchise as kids have all dreamed of becoming a ninja turtle
and anyone who says otherwise is lying to your face
regardless of how cumbersome a shell might be
(distant shouting)
The Revenant
Leo may have won the Oscar but everyone everywhere agrees that the bear was the Revenants real MVP
we've not met one person who disagrees and we probably never will
but in the interest of full disclosure we have to tell you something
that wasn't a real bear
we know you're disappointed we were too until we saw the costume used to simulate the creatures onset presence
and again just like with Jurassic World's raptor costumes we find ourselves overwhelmingly green with envy
now that you're in on the secret we wouldn't be surprised if you added the costume to your Amazon wish list before the sentence was over
(explosions)
Iron Man 2
We've made our love for Robert Downey Jr. crystal clear over the years
but even we have to remember that he's a flesh-and-blood human being
and as such the Iron Man costume must have been as awkward as a cow on ice
thankfully though some merciful soul in the FX Department rigged up some sweet pajamas for Downey Jr. and co-star don Cheadle
sure they still had to wear the helmets of their respective character
but at least it wouldn't take them three hours to go to the bathroom anymore
Superman Returns
So far we've seen examples of motion capture actors being replaced with cooler more interesting big-screen characters
but sometimes people's performances are utilized with the sole intention of erasing them later
that may sound counter-intuitive but in pratice it makes total sense
for example you wouldn't trust a wind machine to do the hard job of blowing Superman's cape just so as he soars through the sky
clearly that kind of work should be left to the professionals
two gentlemen puppeteers in head to toe neon spandex
(screeching) oh yeah exfoliate me
The Jungle Book
Last year's re-imagining of the Jungle Book was great for a lot of reasons
for one it was pretty cool to watch a then 12 year old Neil Sethi act circles around a bunch of seasoned vets
but for many the insane visual effect were the movies crowning achievment
with super convincing animals of all kinds and a steller ensemble cast
it's made almost a billion dollars worldwide
but the reality of filming Sethi's scenes weren't as technologically advanced as you might think